un policier a été traîné au sol suite à
un refus d'obtempéré et le verdict est
tombé ce lundi pour le chauffeur de la
voiture volée il est condamné à 35 heur
de travaux d'intérêt général ça s'est
passé dans les quartiers nord de Nantes
le 2 mai dernier un jeune homme mineur
au moment des faits se retrouve impliqué
dans un refus d'obtempéré ce jour-là le
policier lui demande de sortir du
véhicule mais le mineur le percute et le
traîne au sol sur une vingtaine de
mètres alors qu'il est au volant d'une
voiture volée au moment de lâcher prise
la tête du policier heurte violemment le
bitum et il perd connaissance gros
blackout le policier se souvient juste
avoir senti son ventre racler sur la
route transporté au CHU de il ressort
avec un traumatisme cranien des points
de suture et ce mois-ci il a passé une
IRM qui a démontré qu'il avait des zones
mortes au niveau de son cerveau jugé par
le tribunal correctionnel de Nantes ce
lundi 13 novembre le prévenu a reconnu
les faits et son implication et a été
condamné à 35 heur de travaux d'intérêt
général le parquet lui avait requis un
an de prison avec surc et a déjà annoncé
vouloir faire appel une justice laxiste
et une décision incompréhensible selon
le syndicat il a failli tuer un policier
en uniforme et il n'a rien du tout
dégoûté le policier blessé a quitté
l'audience avant le verdict c'est
honteux je me suis toujours dit ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres collègues
jusqu'au jour où ça m'est arrivé le
syndicat lui dit avoir l'habitude de ce
genre de décision de la part de la
justice annante quand il s'agit de
condamnation contre les policiers les
sanctions sont lourdes mais dans l'autre
sens c'est l'inverse selon Christophe
LAN le juge n'a pas voulu couper la
dynamique de réinsertion du prévenu
dcolarisé au moment des faits il aurait
repris le chemin de l'école il y a peu
et aurait un meilleur comportement
envers ses parents et ses
proches